(enlightening music)
- [Narrator] The River
Ganges in Haridwar, India,
is a holy pilgrimage site
for millions of Hindus
and is visited by hundreds of
thousands of people each year.
(crowd cheering)
It's also home to the largest
handwritten family tree
in the world.
(enlightening music)
For centuries, a sect of
priests known as Pandits
have updated and maintained
comprehensive paper records
on each visitor.
- [Narrator] Each of
the records are sorted
by family lineage and
include reports of births,
deaths and other important events,
many of which span hundreds of years.
- [Narrator] While talks
are underway to digitize
these records, the Pandits take great care
to preserve each delicate
page in hopes of maintaining
family histories for generations to come.